elizabeth warren's high-profile rollout
of her DNA test claiming she's part
Native American
appears to be backfiring the Cherokee
Nation is rejecting the results quote
using a DNA test to lay claim to any
connection to the Cherokee Nation or any
tribal nation even vaguely is
inappropriate and wrong senator Warren
is undermining tribal interests with her
continued claims of tribal heritage
another Cherokee Nation member is
accused in warrant of playing politics
Elizabeth Warren has relied on
stereotypes and popular misconceptions
about Native Americans to prop up her
false claims I think that her decision
shows that she does not listen to native
people and is more concerned about her
own political career and her ambitions
than tribal sovereignty and native
rights
president Trump continuing to go after
Warren tweeting that her stories about
her heritage have turned out to be a
scam and a lie this comes after the
president called on the senator to say
she's sorry for her previous claims she
owes the country an apology only do it
if I can test her personally okay that
will not be something I enjoy doing
either the rest of the Democratic Party
looks to be putting this issue in the
rearview mirror ahead of the midterms
she's put to rest his I think juvenile
offensive and inappropriate suggestions
using his nickname for her that somehow
she didn't over on family history and I
think it's best for everybody if we move
on here and recognize that this is just
another episode that was beneath the
president move on not yet to give you an
opportunity as you remember that I had
my DNA tested a 10.1 percent black point
nine percent actually okay so only more
than her I had more black than she is
Indian yep and imagine if I all of a
sudden started claiming I was black and
I was listed as a minority at college
and Fox News listed me as a member of
the National Black Journalists
Association this is exactly what
Elizabeth Warren did she said she was a
woman of color I think the colors white
that's what the color is
ten years she as a university professor
was claiming to be a minority she said
she was a Cherokee in the cookbook that
she wrote she said her parents were
oppressed because her mother was
Cherokee and then all of a sudden the
Cherokee nation's like nothing Anna Liz
you're not a member of the tribe sorry
and it's all coming unraveling and the
people that are more excited about this
than Donald Trump are Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders because she's cooked as a
candidate it's over for her and I
watched this all unfold yesterday
because I had the sniffles and it was
funny because she came out and thought
she scored it first yes and so did the
media and they sort of demanding Donald
Trump pay off the million-dollar bet and
then all of a sudden now she's at war
with the Cherokee Nation and the media's
writing stories like oh the DNA gambit
may have backfired it's kind of like
this analogy remember the birth
certificate with Barack Obama Juan
imagine if Obama gets the birth
certificate and he looks at it and it's
not up to snuff you know it's forwards
it's not real Bob wah do you think he
would have then put it out that's what
Warren did she got the results and it's
only one one-thousandth and she thought
that that was going to be a winning move
and she put it out that's how out of
touch she is and I'm just astonished
that this is actually happening I think
there mention of their birth certificate
is so timely is it yeah because it's the
same kind of move and guess what
he forced Obama to produce the BRIT he
forces her to go take this test she gets
the guy to say yes you have some
American Indian ancestry right and then
he won't pay her and then he insults
survice this suggests this kind of
sexual suggestion I'm gonna personally
test you that I won't enjoy it
what was that how does that work how do
you test something I guess I don't know
but I'm just gonna say this is so
typical of Trump he makes a promise he
won't pay off the bet she did exactly
what was asked and we remember each to
the sheer absolutely she was the old
question all he said was if you have any
Indian ancestry I will give you a
million bucks by the way it's Mexican
amount
doesn't matter that was what he asked
that's what she did but here's the thing
yes the whole delight that the right is
take taking in the Cherokee Nation
saying this is not right you shouldn't
have done this is about tribal
affiliation it's nothing to do with the
blood test well then watch your color so
put your key in the cookbook in the
cookbook that's what you really worry
about no you know what you're worried
about Jesse I'm worried about
affirmative action that's what this is
let me ask Greg about this because when
it turns to ridicule then you might have
a little bit of a political winner if
you're on the right going against
Elizabeth Warren take a look at this
tweet from Orrin Hatch to the senator
from Utah you know he always makes fun
of his age he's in his 80s and doing
well he says DNA tests are quite
something and it says he's got a little
t-rex very funny very funny
humiliating I mean you don't take a
victory lap after this debacle I mean
this to put in perspective this makes
Michael Dukakis in the tank look like
tear down the wall I mean this is
something you will never forget she is
she is cooked she might get out of it
because it's two years from now but in
my mind she's cooked I mean speaking of
Cherokee she has more in common with the
Jeep with the tribe and that's why they
kicked her off the reservation because
they she that it was just insulting to
them that she for the second time was
exploiting Native Americans before her
own advancement first too you know in
college and now this and they knew it
and it disgusted them and by the way to
the point about Trump he doesn't owe her
wampum because because he said if she's
Indian if she's in it
he didn't say party and he said if she's
Indian and in the fact is if the
majority or again said when European
Americans have more Native American
blood than she does which is the case
according the New York Times and me
being two percent Native American he
doesn't owe her a dime
however he should donate some money
perhaps to a Native American fund just
just to show that he's a bigger man but
this is great this is where identity
politics takes you and the beauty of
this is I say it again when you apply
for a job where diversity Trump's
experience they should staple your DNA
test to you
or SAT scores or application and that's
gonna kill all of this see that's what
we're really talking about I mean so
let's get beyond the static and the
gossip we also got to get you I just
think that's what we're talking about is
the white identity investigation she
benefited in no way at Harbor floor this
is the ultimate cultural appropriation
by Elizabeth Warren Sobrero so much
worse and she benefited off of it for 30
years by listing herself in these
directories that said she was Native
American which were used as hedge hunter
portfolios for schools like Harvard law
to look at lists of peoples who are
interested in getting more diversity
into their loss there's not collateral
she some of the schools might have used
and said that about her but she never
used it which is a benefit to Elizabeth
Warren and getting ahead tonight she
actually did a video again exploiting
Native Americans and why did she seek
out the Stanford academic anyway instead
of using a commercial product like we
did on the 5 because she needed an ally
she needed someone to finesse this
fabrication and they found this guy
poured this poor guy Bustamonte a were
just like their white meat
why you asking me to do this as an
expert how about that yeah but you know
what is he an expert when he didn't even
test the proper DNA against what they
were looking for the ruinous
knives in a try expert now let me give a
last word of Jesse just about how that
you saw Democrats wanting to move on
from this they wish he hadn't done it
the timing is terrible well anybody let
this go yeah no Democrats are out there
complaining that she didn't need to do
this now three weeks before the midterm
elections we're talking about Michael a
vanetti we're talking about Elizabeth
Warren are these people being paid by
the RNC yeah his team